welcome it's morning where i am but if
it's not morning where you are then i'll
just say welcome otherwise good morning
to everyone who's attending today if
you're not aware already you are able to
obtain
continuing education or ce credits for
this presentation so do look for that on
your screen and it should be rather
obvious to you
so um i was asked to speak about
epigenetic complications in
myeloproliferative neoplasms and i
recognize that there are a number of
different uh people that are going to be
attending these types of sessions and so
if you are very very familiar with
epigenetics and their role in cancers
and their normal roles and cells
some of this might be a little bit
remedial but if you are unfamiliar with
epigenetics then hopefully i'll be able
to explain to you some of the
basic principles of epigenetics and also
how those um these molecules that are
involved in epigenetics are contributing
to normal cells and also to an abnormal
phenotype
so the objectives uh for this talk today
are first of all to be able to define
epigenetics i hope that i'll be able to
explain that well enough that you can uh
use a pretty good definition also to
look at the impact of the somatic
mutations
and how um epigenetic control of gene
expression is going to be um
worked into a myeloproliferative
neoplasm
and finally to be able to identify some
of the therapeutic approaches that are
currently being used to target
epigenetic mechanisms and some of the
new molecules that potentially might be
used
in the future
i included this image on
on this screen from an artist named
roman varasco
and he his quote is that early on i
learned to wonder about the marvelous
event of things existing
just the way they are
and whether there could be other ways to
be
i i liked this idea this quote i liked
the image because he was a computer
programmer and was looking at art in a
different way and developing art in a
different way
than the traditional way of thinking
about how art could be developed and he
was using computer programs to be able
to produce his art so i think that a lot
of times we think of
problems with dna or
problems when we when we see chromosomal
changes in cancer and we think of it
very uniquely within the dna level but
that's just thinking about things the
way that we already understand them
there's more to it than that and
epigenetics is one of those
mechanisms that takes us beyond
the way things are and thinking about
other ways
that
dna can be
uh so
um genetics can i'm sorry epigenetics
can be defined
as on top of genetics suggesting that
what we're doing when we have an
epigenetic mechanism that's altering
gene expression is that we're not just
looking at a base change within the dna
we're not looking at changing a's to t's
or um you know changing the the the
actual nucleotide sequence but what
we're doing is changing the chemical
structure of either the dna or the other
proteins that are interacting with the
dna and in either case uh the the
expression of the gene is going to be
changed
so we're not talking about um genetics
in the sense of the nucleotide sequence
but something that is above that or
literally on top of that as a chemical
modification
the information of the genome
is is encoded for by the dna but in an
epigenetic mechanism we have additional
information that can be thought of as
not just being carried by the nucleotide
sequence something additional to that
and certainly epigenetics are heritable
and we see
the way that certain genes are inherited
depending on whether or not they come
from a mom or they come from dad and
that's a mechanism called imprinting but
we also see that there are changes in
the way that um dna is going to be
expressed from one mitotic cell division
to the next and that that is an
epigenetic mechanism that carries on to
the offspring at the cellular level so
so epigenetics are heritable changes
in gene expression but not just due to
changes within the dna sequence
so when we think about epigenetics in a
definition we certainly want to think of
dna as giving the nucleotide sequence
and giving a plan for the genome but
there are several other factors that are
going to contribute to how that plan is
actually going to be carried out how
those genes are actually going to be
expressed
when um considering which uh
all the different types of cells that
exist within the body how is it possible
that some of these cells look so very
different from each other and have such
very different functions
from each other um it's uh easy to see
when you when you look at these various
um types of slides
sorry i'm trying to pull up my uh
my note tools here so up here at the top
we have a
um a neuron we also have a beautiful my
favorite of our myeloid cells and
eosinophil and then there's the muscle
cells and some um
columnar epithelium um
all shown below here in in any of these
cases
uh what
sorry what we have is that we are are
looking at all of these different cell
types that all have the same dna within
their core
but there are other mechanisms that are
allowing these cells to differentiate
into the cell types that they are going
to function as and it's an epigenetic
mechanism that contributes to which
genes are going to be turned on and
which genes are going to be left off or
in other words you could think of this
as being
expressed or silenced
so when we think of dna we can't just
think of the nucleotide sequence and
just say okay well we have all these
nucleotides in a particular arrangement
and that's what's going to give us the
open reading frame for a gene and that's
all there is to it we can't really think
of dna within the nucleus as being
quote quote-unquote naked
um there there certainly are other
molecules that are wrapping up the dna
and the uh um histones that are involved
in that as we wrap the dna around those
histones we wind them into what we call
a nucleosome
and that's also what's referred to as
the beads on a string
which is always kind of fun to think of
and um you could you could think of your
pearl necklace and those being the the
individual pearls having dna wrapped
around them and that would be your um
your nucleosomes
those nucleosomes are also going to be
coiled and turned such that they will
form the chromosomes and ultimately in
order to have any uh gene be expressed
from this very very tightly condensed
chromosome we have to be able to open
the dna so that we can um incorporate
rna polymerase and transcription factors
to actually be able to interact with the
dna to transcribe those genes but then
when that process is done and when that
gene is no longer needed to be expressed
we have to have a mechanism to tighten
everything back up so that these genes
aren't going to be constitutively
expressed
so that's the role of these various
types of proteins that are going to be
winding the dna and bringing it very
close together or opening it back up
again to allow for genes to be expressed
so when um when we when we consider that
there are these different types of
compaction within the chromosomes we can
refer to those various
uh compacted areas as being either
heterochromatin which is very very
tightly compacted or condensed
when we look at it microscopically the
morphology of that chromatin is that
it's going to be very very darkly
stained
and it would functionally be
transcriptionally inactive dna on the
other hand
in contrast to
heterochromatin is euchromatin which is
very open and widely expressed
and if we're looking at the morphology
of those types of cells and what we will
be looking at is a very light stain
very more pinkish uh than purple having
to do with the basophilic or acetophilic
dyes that are going to be used to stain
our cells
um and this would be transcriptionally
active
dna
so when we when we think about whether
or not we have that very tightly
condensed or darkly stained dna versus
very light stained dna we can consider
that we have genes that are able to be
exposed and expressed versus genes that
are very tightly wound within the dna
and not able to be expressed at all so
up here on the top
uh we have a pygnotic cell actually this
is a neutrophil on its way to exiting
out of its life it has performed its
function and it's no longer going to be
with us um but but it's it's a nice
style um to consider along the lines of
heterochromatin because that chromatin
is very very very tightly condensed
probably um a little bit more condensed
than we would think of for any other
normal type cell
whereas
below here we have a
if any of you are clinical pathologists
or medical laboratory scientists you
probably recognize this
as a myeloblast and you know for sure
that it's a myeloblast because you can
see these our rods right here and it
looks like there might be one right here
as well so these our rods suggest to us
that we don't just have any old blast we
indeed have a myeloblast and i bring up
these two cells because this brings us
to this idea of myeloproliferative
neoplasms and um
certainly we would be encountering
myeloblasts and other
myeloid cells like neutrophils
within the context of a
myeloproliferative
neoplastic disorder
so the epigenetic code that gets us to
this heterochromatin and euchromatin is
going to exist in a number of different
um
categories but some of the the most
common categories that we think of have
to do with dna methylation histone
modifications and non-coding rna also
known as
microrna or silencing rna depending on
what school you come from
in the context of histone modifications
we also have a number of subcategories
that can be included within that
including
acetylation and deacetylation
methylation and demethylation and
phosphorylation and dephosphorylation
all of which are going to be
contributing to the compaction of of the
dna i um when i'm teaching about
epigenetics and histones within
a classroom setting i tend to discuss
acetylation um most frequently because
it's it's a little bit easier to
understand than some of the other
mechanisms and then when you add acetyl
groups to these histones you're
basically pushing the dna out and so it
makes it easier for that dna to be
exposed to rna polymerase because you're
pushing it outwards you take off those
acetyl groups and you tighten the dna
back up and it makes it more difficult
for rna polymerase to be able to
transcribe those genes in those areas
so
each of these categories more clearly
defined
dna methylation is when we have some
sort of a chemical modification to the
dna molecule
and this is carried out by an enzyme
called dna methyl transferase there are
a handful of dna methyl transferases
all of which i'm not going to discuss
but it's important to recognize a couple
of differences um that are more uh that
we see with epigenetics more commonly so
with dna methyl transferase one this is
an enzyme that
is involved in maintenance
uh methylation
and so when we when we are using uh dna
methyl transferase one we are taking the
an existing dna methylation pattern and
putting it into the daughter strand
during the process of dna replication so
the origin of replication
within a eukaryotic cell is going to be
uh well actually within prokaryotes as
well but with any i only care about
eukaryotes for the time being
um
uh the origin of replication as it is
opening up to be replicated that origin
uh the the parental strand is going to
be methylated
and as the daughter strand is being
generated it stays as unmethylated and
so when we have this
so-called hemi-methylated dna it's a
signal to the cell to uh suggest that
replication's not quite done yet let's
wait until this whole process is
finished and then
dna methyltransferase one can come back
through the origin of replication and
methylate adenine residues within that
origin to suggest that now replication
is over and we have this maintenance
methylation that that is going to be
present
dna methyl transferase 3
there's 3a and 3b
both are involved in de novo
methylation and they are involved in the
methylation of cytosines to a 5-methyl
cytosine
and so these are considered to establish
on a
uh
the dna methylation pattern within a
cell and also are um used to con to
contribute to which genes should be
turned off when it's a as a cell is
trying to differentiate into its various
types in that image that we saw that had
a um
an eosinophil and columnar epithelium
and a neuron all of these different cell
types have to have specific genes turned
off while others are allowed to remain
on
so in in trying to uh
get a sense of these methylation
patterns
at the top here we have cytosine and
it's a dna methyl transferase that adds
that methyl group right there so at the
bottom we would see that we have dna
that's unmethylated
and during the process of of dna
replication we ultimately end up
methylating that
that
origin of replication here it's showing
that it's cytosine but regardless of the
point uh we methylate on using
maintenance methylation during this
process and then denotable methylation
would be conducted by our
dnmt3s
when looking at
dna methylation how the silencing
actually occurs
has to do with cpg islands uh cpg simply
suggests that there is a phosphodiester
bond between cytosine and guanine within
the uh
within the um sequence of the dna so
when we see these cpg islands
it's generally a short region within
within the dna
and um it's only called the cpg island
because the the number of uh c's and g's
or cytosines and guanines within that
sequence is much higher than it is in
other regions and they're frequently
found near the promoter regions of um of
certain genes and and in in any given
cell at any given time somewhere between
70 and 80 percent of the um of the genes
would be methylated and it acts as a
silencing mechanism it provides the
methylation profile for any given cell
and within its genome
um so the that methylation profile is
going to be lineage dependent it allows
for these cells to differentiate and to
become the various functional cell types
that they can be
and it um
also allows for a very unique set of
proteins to be expressed
from those specific genes
such that we are going to have the
actual function being
displayed by those cells
in order for these cpg islands to be
able to work there's two mechanisms by
which they do so
within a cpg island if it becomes
methylated then what we see is
what we see is a methyl binding protein
sorry um what we see is that a
protein that would be activating an
enhancer region or a regulatory
transcription
region of a particular gene would be
inhibited from binding if we happen to
have a number of different methylation
groups there
we can also see that there are certain
methyl cpg binding proteins that tend to
interact with highly methylated regions
of dna and recruit in other enzymes such
as histone deacetylases as shown down
here
and if you recall i mentioned a minute
ago that when we have a histone um
deacetylase then it tends to tighten up
the dna and make it so those particular
gene sequences can't be expressed or are
much more difficult to be expressed in
those in those regions
so cpg islands are um
when they're methylated are very much
involved in in gene silencing
histone modifications are where we're
going to be focusing most of our
attention today um and specifically uh
with histone three but also a little bit
of histone two
um histones are acting as those spools
to wrap around the dna in what we call a
nucleosome and there's actually four
different histones that interact with
each other
in uh dimers such that we have a histone
october
and when we have this histone octamer
that's what functions very well to
tighten up the dna
so when uh there are alterations to
those histones it's considered to be a
post-translational
histone modification meaning that the
protein has been translated and then
after it's been translated there is a
new modification that's made to that
protein that's why it's called a
post-translational modification
and these modifications are going to be
contributing to the to the way that the
chromatin is going to be compacted
um
if if again we see that the chromatin is
very tightly compacted little to no
transcription or if we allow for the
chromatin to be opened then we have far
more
transcription that can potentially
happen
um there are uh modifications to the
histones that are considered to be
covalent but they are reversible uh so
acetylation phosphorylation and
methylation are all going to be
contributing to the changes in in the
way that these histones are going to be
functioning
um histone three is where we'll be uh
looking mostly today
and it is so this molecule here it's
just a globular protein that's got a
tail on it um lots of lysines within
that within that tail all of the tails
not shown here but essentially we're
going to be looking at quite a few
methylating events that can occur within
that tail
whether or not we're looking at any of
these
types of chemical reactions biochemical
reactions acetylation phosphorylation or
methylation any of these are going to
result in some kind of a change in the
way that the histones are going to
interact with the dna changing its
compaction or it might be altering the
way that these histones would be acting
interacting rather with other proteins
to allow for an increase or decrease in
the transcription of those uh genes that
it's interacting with
so the last epigenetic mechanism that
can be considered is rna interference
in which we are using
a short rna sequence that base pairs
very very tightly or not so tightly in
either case
it interacts with another mrna creating
a double-stranded mrna and that uh or i
guess you wouldn't necessarily call it a
double-stranded mrna but at least it's a
double-stranded rna and so it inhibits
the mrna from actually being able to
interact with the ribosome and have that
mrna translated so it's an inhibitory
mechanism to reduce the expression
of those rnas this is contributing um to
uh
in part to the tissue specific
expression profile as well just like
methylation and histone modifications
are
um so when we do have micro rnas
interacting with our mrnas we create
these double strands that can either
cause the rna the mrna to be degraded
immediately or it just inhibits its
translational ability through the
ribosome
so what's the outcome of all of these
epigenetic modifications they're really
quite fascinating um we have here on on
the left we have our our uh friendly um
myeloblast again maybe not so friendly
considering that he's probably going to
be contributing to
um our acute myeloproliferative
disorders and then over here rather than
showing you a pygnotic
neutrophil here's a just regular
neutrophil we can argue about whether or
not we call this a band or a sag in
either case it's on its way to being a
segmented neutrophil such that it would
have its full
functional capacity
and you can think of the epigenetics
within each of each of these cells and
think about the chromatin compaction
that you would see within each of these
cells based on looking at the staining
characteristics of the nucleus
so within the
um myeloblast on this side uh we would
have you can see that there's a nucleoli
um and that the the chromatin is very
open and very it's very light and
staining and therefore it's probably
much more transcriptionally active
because it is so much more open it's a
very large nucleus as well
so in this case we would say that there
are probably lots of um
histone acetyl transferases working
allowing for
acetylation of those histones and
allowing for the basal transcriptional
apparatus the general transcription
factors like tf2d to be able to interact
with the promoter regions of genes and
also to be able to recruit in rna
polymerase so that we can actually
transcribe some of those genes
on the other hand if you look back over
here at our uh segmented neutrophil the
chromatin is very tightly compacted very
very tightly compacted very dark and
staining
and so what we have on this side is that
there's probably all kinds of histone
diacetylases and and um repressors of of
histone methyl transferases and lots of
other dna methyl transferases that are
silencing all different kinds of genes
within those cells so that the only
genes that are going to be able to be
functional are those that are going to
be useful for the immediate outcome of
that cell for whatever it is that that
cell is trying to
um
to work on at that particular moment
whereas on the myeloblast side again you
have lots of different genes because
there are um there's this cell still has
the potential to not only um divide but
also to to differentiate into what it
will ultimately become as a
neutrophil segmented neutrophil
since we're talking about
hematopoiesis i thought it would be
a prime time to discuss the
hematopoietic stem cell development and
how these cells are going to be coming
um going to uh turn into the the various
cell types that we're going to be
discussing today
so um in the
starting off here on on the left we have
a hematopoietic stem cell and this
hematopoietic stem cell has self-renewal
capacity and it has true self-renewal
capacity and i've created these sort of
crude images down here at the bottom to
suggest that um the the chromatin
or the
not within certainly one chromosome but
within the genome um that there's going
to be information within that genome
that's more readily expressed within our
hematopoietic stem cell so gene
expression you could think of as being
the pale blue staining area and those
genes that have
already been turned off to give us the
differentiation of the hematopoietic
stem cell are going to be very dark and
blue
whereas when you
reach some of the um later cell types
like the common myeloid progenitor um
the uh myeloid erythroid progenitor
uh the granulocytic myeloid progenitor
and all of these
young progenitor type cells the bfue the
the burst forming unit
um erythroid and burst forming unit
megacare acidic and all of these cell
types what you have is now that you're
starting to shut down some of those
genes you're tightly compact compacting
those genes so that we are reducing the
potential for other genes to be
expressed and only allowing for those
genes that are going to allow for
differentiation along that particular
line to be expressed
once we reach the uni potential stage
somewhere around the colony forming unit
stage
and beyond certainly well beyond into
the myeloblast
stage when we're considering that we're
just concerned with uh the myeloid cells
for this talk um that's when we're going
to be shutting down lots of different
genes so you can see that you have much
much more dark blue staining area within
that genome and
very little of the light blue staining
area because we have created an
opportunity to only express those genes
that are going to give us those
particular cell types that will function
the way that they're supposed to
and the the problem with uh
myeloproliferative neoplasms is that
there are certainly some unique gene
sequences that are altered
but we can also uh consider some of
those um light blue seeming areas and
dark blue seeming areas or uh colored
areas within the genome
pictorial um to be altered in a way that
they're not supposed to be so with the
myeloproliferative neoplasms we um can
consider
several more than what i've listed here
the the who 2008 classification includes
far more categories than what i've
listed but we're mostly concerned with
just a few of these so um
it's important to remember that
chronic myeloid leukemia uh is going to
be bcr able one positive and it is
diagnostic
when bcr able1 is present that we will
be calling this chronic myocytic
leukemia
on the other hand if beasts are able
one is negative
then we're going to be categorizing all
of these myeloproliferative neoplasms
along this particular umbrella and
there's a number of different gene
sequences that are involved in
contributing to the transformation of
these different cell types and these
disorders
the uh the cell types that i'll be
talking about briefly today are
essential thrombocytemia polycythemia
vera and primary myelofibrosis chronic
neutrophilic leukemia mastocytosis and
eosinophilia could potentially fall
under the categories of epigenetic
alterations there haven't been enough to
been described as yet but that being
said the epigenetic modifications that
we know of are really really new so
there's um a possibility that we're
going to start seeing more studies to
bring out some more information about
these other myeloproliferative disorders
as well
uh myelodysplastic syndrome i will
mention a few times um because we see
some of the exact same epigenetic
alterations in um
uh in the myeloproliferative disorders
that we see in myelodysplastic syndromes
and
acute myeloid leukemia
um this is when the bone marrow needs to
show uh greater than um or equal to 20
blasts within the bone marrow but we
also see some of the same epigenetic
modifications in those as well so so
that's going to be mentioned
periodically throughout this talk
also
first starting off before we get into
the epigenetic modifications i think
it's important to recognize what we have
with the um
more common uh
genetic alterations that we see in
myeloproliferative neoplasms
first of all with bcr able one
again that's going to be diagnostic for
chronic myeloid leukemia and this is a
922 translocation in which uh this
translocation leads to a
fusion protein called vcr one
this b sierra able one is going to be
involved in a number of different signal
transduction pathways all of which are
going to be contributing
to
things that are particularly
problematic in uh leukemia um including
migration proliferation and also
survival of the cells so when we have
this bcr able1 uh fusion protein
generated then what we see is that there
is some
significant increase in the
proliferation and survival ability of
these cells
it's important to note that we can also
diagnose
cml
even when the large chromosomal
translocation isn't present as long as
we see the fusion protein uh bcr l1 as
being positive within these cells then
we do consider that to be diagnostic of
chronic myelogenous leukemia
within all of the others for our bcr
able one negative myeloproliferative
neoplasms um there are certainly some
other gene mutations including jack 2
which many of you probably um are
probably familiar with this is janus
kinase ii it's a non-receptor tyrosine
uh kinase that interacts with a number
of different receptors the image that
i've shown you here has to do with ebola
receptor but it's also going to interact
with with a few others
so essentially when epo um the ipo
receptor interacts with its uh ligand
ipo
that activates stimulates turns on jack
2 which causes an activation of stat 5
which then dimerizes and moves into the
nucleus to transcribe its target genes
when there is a very unique and specific
mutation the jac2
v617f mutation
this is when a
um we have an amino acid substitution
and the 617th amino acid from um
phenylalanine is present in the mutated
uh jack 2 whereas
valine is supposed to be present in the
non-mutated form of jack 2.
essentially when we have this v617f
mutation there is essentially no need
for uh there to be cytokine present and
we end up having a fully functional and
activated jack 2 to activate step 5 to
translocate into the nucleus and
activate its target genes
the jack ii mutation is observed in
a very very high percentage of our
polycythemia vera patients
and lasso in
essential thrombocytemia and primary
myelofibrosis
however there is a
fair fairly large number of patients
that both
are that express these mutations as well
nipple is a uh
a gene encoding for the typo receptor
and
there are a number of mutations that
have been identified within um within
the nipple as well and essentially um
this uh these mutations lead to
a constitutively active receptor that
then constitutively activates jack too
so it's a little bit higher up within
the signal transduction pathway so when
we have these nipple mutations either um
a change in um
uh from tryptophan to either leucine or
lysine then what we see is a um
thrombocytosis and myelofibrosis so
these are seen in in both etn and pmf
patients
link mutations um in the are also
observed in our myeloproliferative
neoplasm patients link is supposed to uh
negatively regulate jack too it's
supposed to inhibit jack ii
and when it is uh
um
inhibited or mutated let's say um
then it allows for uh the um jack to to
be able to interact with stat when it
isn't necessarily supposed to so um
there are mutations within the link
molecule that are known to contribute to
the npn phenotype as well
and um it is certainly seen as an
increase within the blast phase of those
patients that are progressing into acute
myeloid leukemia
so as you've seen there's a high
percentage of these particular
genes that are mutated bcr able um
nipple and link but there are lots of
other
diseases that we see uh mpns that we see
that don't have those particular
mutations
so there has to be something outside of
that so the evidence for the for these
genetic
events outside of the jack stack pathway
are suggested when we have all of these
patients that have pmf and et but they
don't have any of the other mutations
that we've just discussed
furthermore we see this jack 2 mutation
that's
present in these various
mpn's how is it possible that one
mutation in one
uh gene protein ultimately can give us
three different phenotypes it doesn't
make sense so there must be something
outside of just jack two that's
contributing to the phenotype and that's
where
a number of different groups had started
looking into the epigenetic mechanisms
of other
molecules and how those could be
contributing to these phenotypes
so the epigenetic regulators that are
associated with the mpns um the most
common ones that have been described at
least
are listed here i created this table to
sort of bring together all of these
different epigenetic molecules what the
mutations are what the um overall effect
is that the mutations lead to for the
protein function
and the hematologic abnormality that is
observed um not all of which that are
listed here are mpns but most of which
are
milo dysplastic syndrome certainly shows
up
as does acute myelogenous leukemia in
several of these
altered molecules epigenetic regulators
it's important to note that
these uh epigenetic regulators don't
necessarily have names that we would
commonly think of in the eukaryotic
world
um
in the human world i guess i should say
um because many of these molecules were
first described in drosophila and our
drosophila researchers are a happy group
of people and they come up with some
really cool names
i'd love to sit down and have a beer
with a drosophila person at some point
in my life and find out how in the world
they come up with some of these names
um
some of which are unique to drosophila
and others of which are completely off
the wall so asxl1
is the additional sex cones like
transcriptional regulator one but that
was a the name arised within drosophila
and has a homologue has been found
within humans as well and it's been
identified in a number of different
hematologic disorders um
especially um within pv and et and pmf
as being a problem here so i'm going to
go through each one of these um
individually but just keep that in mind
that they don't necessarily always tell
you what they do just because uh they
have kind of a funny name
so asxl1 is the most frequently observed
uh
regulator that is altered
thus far and it's
involved in
interacting with a complex called the
polycomb repressive complex prc2 and
also
potentially is involved in interacting
with another complex called prc1
the specific role that it plays within
these two complexes is not
terribly well understood at this point
but it is observed to at least interact
with these complexes and it's thought to
possibly stabilize the complexes
from these images
you can see that
you can see that asxl1 interacting with
this
prc2 complex is going to be involved in
a methylating event and it's going to be
methylating
one particular histone histone 3 at
lysine number 27 but it's also involved
in um in this side over here with prc1
and it's going to be um involved in a
ubiquitination with uh histone 2.
um so there's a number of different
lines of evidence to suggest that it's
working on both complexes and
interacting with both histone 3 and
histone 2.
i guess i should continue on and in any
case when we do have this
methylation of these histones it
contributes to a compaction and a
tightening up of these
of the dna within these regions and it
blocks the ability of rna polymerase to
be able to function the way that it
normally would
so the
asx l1 mutation was identified in
myeloproliferative neoplasms it wasn't
identified itself in 2009 but it was
identified in milo proliferative
neoplasms in 2009 so i mentioned earlier
that
many of these disorders are
and mutations are rather new and
they've all been identified in the last
four or five years and so that being
said that's why there's still a lot of
questions that are associated with how
these epigenetic regulators are working
but there's a few things that are that
are known
so um in
primary myelofibrosis and
myelodysplastic syndrome patients it has
been observed that when there are as xl1
mutations that both patients do have a
shortened survival
uh and the function of asxl1 is um again
to modify the histones
through
interaction with the prc2 complex but
how exactly it interacts with that
complex is not well understood
but it does appear to be very important
for asxl1 to be present in order for
that prc2 complex to be able to function
within hematopoietic stem cells and very
important to allow for differentiation
along the myeloid line and when asxl1 is
eliminated completely it contributes to
bone marrow complete failure
so when we have loss of function
mutations um within asx l1
there is an essential uh reduction in
methylation throughout the entire genome
um and especially within that histone
three
at the 27th glycine within histone three
so
um in losing uh this this repression of
of
of gene expression
what we can see is that there are a
number of different target genes some of
which are not well understood as of yet
but one of which has been um supposed to
be problematic is a hox gene hox a9 and
this is involved this is a gene that's
involved in development and when we lose
its
repression we allow for it to be
expressed when it's not supposed to be
and this is potentially going to be
contributing to
the myeloproliferative
neoplastic phenotype when we start
expressing genes that are supposed to be
involved in development in adulthood
so we see this chromatin being in a
relaxed state so again here's histone
number three the 27th lysine is not
shown in this particular image but
you could suppose that there would be a
number of different other molecules
within this histone tail and that's the
27th lysine is where we have the
potential problem but recall that those
histones are involved in wrapping up the
dna and so when you don't have asx l1
working the way that it's supposed to
the prc2 complex can't work the way that
it's supposed to and there's no
methylation that's going to be occurring
to tighten up the dna in those various
spots
so the next epigenetic regulator that's
most commonly identified um second to um
asx l1
is the uh easy h2 molecule
and this one was identified in a number
of different myelo proliferative
neoplasms in 2010
and certainly also in mds
and it's been associated its alteration
has been associated again with a
shortened survival
in those patients that carry an easy h2
mutation so easy h2 is um
supposed to be the catalytic number of
the prc2 complex and you saw that on the
previous
slide you saw that asxl1 was holding
that complex together but easyh
two is
actually contributing to the um
enzymatic methylation
or the methyl transferase activity of
that particular complex
so um when we have point mutations in
ezh2 then there are um
there is a um reduced ability to be able
to uh silence various genes um and on
the flip side of that um there is
supposed uh an oncogenic role for easy
h2 to be able to
work as well so we can see that there
are both loss of function and gain of
function mutations in easy h2 and
whether or not
those those mutations happen to be
present seems to
at the very least seems to lead to the
various phenotypes and the various types
of cancers so um the easy h2 molecule
appears to function as a tumor
suppressor in
myeloproliferative neoplasms whereas it
appears to function as an oncogene
in several other cancers
essentially when
when
easyh
two
sorry i'm kind of losing some of my
tools here when ezh2
is uh not functioning the way that it's
supposed to we end up turning um
allowing for genes to be expressed um
because they are they're going to be
exposed that lysine 27 is not on histone
three it's not going to be methylated
whereas when we have easy h2 being
overexpressed then we have lots and lots
of lysine 27 and histone 3 being
methylated and transcription is turned
off
so it's uh it's interesting to look at
this easy h2 molecule and how it's going
to be functioning in either a tumor
suppressor or oncogene um again it seems
to appear
it seems to be functioning as a tumor
suppressor within the myeloproliferative
neoplasms but how uh the the various
genes that are downstream of that have
not been well described at least um
as of yet
so um it's interesting to note that um
easy h2 is found on chromosome 7
and if you recall from your pathology
days that myelodysplastic syndromes have
the minus 7 and the 7q deletion
syndromes
both of which are going to have been
observed at least those large
chromosomal changes have been observed
in
mds and since we have this particular
molecule found within
chromosome number seven when we lose
those very large regions it's very
likely that it's because of this loss in
ezh2 that we're leading to the phenotype
of mds
um there are other point mutations that
have been observed in in easy h2 that
reduce its um
methylating activity
uh there's also been um a few uh mrnas
that have been sorry mi rnas that have
been described that appear to
contribute to regulation of easy h2 as
well those are mostly described in some
b-cell disorders however
and it's also important to note that the
phosphorylation site of
easyh2 contributes to whether or not it
is going to be active or repressed
so mick has been um linked to the
expression of easy h2 rather closely and
this image that i've shown below here
shows how the easy h2 can function in a
normal tumor suppressor capacity
when mec is at low levels um or
acting the way that it probably should
in a normal cell type then easy h2 is
going to be
this is on the left side of the screen
here easy h2 is going to be
phosphorylated and it's not going to be
um
inhibiting the genes that it normally or
commonly would be
on the other hand when mick is at very
high levels of which we see in um
somewhere of 70 percent of all cancers
we see increased expression of neck
this uh activates this p10 pathway which
then dephosphorylates easy h2
and um easy h2 is very readily able to
silence many of the mic associated
target proteins uh and including neck
itself so easy h2 functions very well in
the tumor suppressor role especially
when we see this nick over activation
however if easy h2 is gone
then we completely lose this whole side
and the ability of easy h2 to be able to
function as a tumor suppressor
molecule on the flip side of that when
we have easy h2 functioning as an
oncogene um it's functioning within the
cell cycle pathway
and it's going to be phosphorylated on a
different residue in the previous slide
it was
phosphorylated on um
let's go back back to that one for just
a second because i can't ever remember
serine 21. however when we phosphorylate
it at uh threonine 350 then we're
changing its expression pathway
so here we can see that we have ech2
phosphorylated on threonine 350 and it
is going to be activated by the cdks
ddk1 and 2 and its normal role would
then be to work through
some of the cdkis or the
cyclin-dependent kinase inhibitors
including p15 16 and p14 as well um
and it can function to to um
and when it's being phosphorylated and
it's being activated we can start
turning off some of those genes so it
can act in an oncogenic role in
inhibiting the cyclin-dependent kinase
inhibitors and allowing for the cell
cycle to progress
unchecked we end up having this promoted
cell proliferation when we shouldn't
all right the next epigenetic
regulator
hopefully you're not going into a
whirlwind of despair that there are so
many epigenetic regulators so tech two
the um uh 1011 translocation 2 molecule
was identified again just a few years
ago 2009
and was shown to be altered in both mpn
patients and mds patients
tattoo requires a substrate alpha
ketoglutarate to be able to work and
it's encoding an enzyme that contributes
to the demethylation of dna
so when we have 5-methyl cytosine type 2
contributes to 5-hydroxy methyl cytosine
which is the first step in getting dna
to be unmethylated so that we can start
expressing some of those genes
the mutations that have been observed in
tattoo have been
inactivating
mutations suggesting that two can no
longer
allow for certain genes to be expressed
and it has been observed in all of the
mpn subtypes so far
um and it's been uh there was um
speculation a few years ago that uh that
jack 2 had to be mutated first in order
to be able to see the tattoo mutations
that it was a subsequent mutating event
but in fact it's been shown to be
mutated even before jack 2. the v617f
mutation has been observed so there are
cells that have been
identified to have
the genotype of both tattoo mutant and
the
jack ii v617f including the
normal
jack 2 wild type and also to see
tattoo mutations
that are
found before we end up seeing the jak-2
v617 mutants
so in um
in the context of the way that tattoo is
going to be functioning
it's changing the way that our cells are
going to be allowed to self-renew
especially when we're looking at the
hematopoietic stem cells so if at the
top here you can see that there are
certain genes that have these five
methyl cytosine regions that two is
supposed to be involved in
helping to demethylate
those regions such that we are going to
take our hematopoietic stem cells and
block the ability for them to undergo
self-renewal and start differentiating
in an appropriate fashion
on the other hand when we eliminate
tattoo from being able to work the way
that it's supposed to those methylated
regions
are not going to have the same
demethylation patterns
that we would typically see so not only
can we see some of the self-renewal of
altered cell types but we can also see a
dysregulation in the differentiation of
the cells leading to the mpn and on
several other myeloid proliferative
disorders um phenotype so mds has been
observed with with these sorts of type 2
mutations as well
dnmt3 dna methyltransferase iii
identified in the myeloid malignancies
just again a couple of years ago in 2010
recall that dnmt3 is supposed to be
involved
in de novo cytosine methylation and
establishing the methylation pattern
within cells so that they can become the
functional cell type that they're
supposed to um when we see loss of
functions mutation loss of function
mutations in dnmt3a
there is um
a sort of perplexing event that that
occurs um there has been observed um
for there to be some correlation with
the nmt3a mutations
and the gene expression that that should
be present but there's also been
observed to have no phenotype at all
from the cnmt3a mutations um it's it's
because it's a rather new one we still
have to do a little bit more research in
finding out how dnmt3 is going to be
working to contribute to the phenotype
but certainly it has been involved in
the npns at some point
so the dnm t3s
dnmt as you can see are going to be
involved in um
to be involved over here um and
methylating again that lysine um 27 on
histone number three um and contributing
to whether or not those genes are
supposed to be silenced
so um the genes that are supposed to be
repressed for our normal stem cell
differentiation up here
to be contributing to an upregulated and
hypomethylated
phenotype in the mpns
idh1 and 2 the last one of the
epigenetic regulators i promise
this one is um identified in both mds
and mpns within um the last four years
in 2010 and they've been observed in
last phase of npn or the the transition
to acute myeloid leukemia and has been
observed in uh primary myelofibrosis to
have a
much worse survival rate in those
individuals
um if you recall glycolysis
our idhs are involved in um
the decarboxylation to of isocitrate to
give us alpha-ketoglutarate
alpha-ketoglutarate if you recall was
that substrate for tet-2
so we actually need functioning idh
1 and 2 to be able to give us the
appropriate um response of tattoo so
when idh1 and 2 go wrong we're not
producing the appropriate substrate or
tet2 to be able to function the way that
it's supposed to
so idh1 and 2 is the only molecule that
appears to have a gain of function
mutation and to somehow act in like an
oncogenic type role
such that when we see these mutations we
have altered enzymatic activity of idh1
and 2 and it essentially pulls away
alpha-ketoglutarate
from
tattoo such that type 2 can no longer
work the way that it's supposed to
because it doesn't have its appropriate
substrate so it results in a um uh
a methylation profile of those genes
that would be required to help properly
differentiate to the functional forms of
those white cells myeloid cells
so we end up seeing in those individuals
that have idh1 and 2 mutations we end up
seeing decreased survival but especially
in primary myelofibrosis
so this is a pathway that came out of
the ash book a couple of years ago and i
have all the references for all these
images at the very end of this if you
are interested in going back to look at
what some of these different um papers
were
but uh what i really liked about this
mutation is not only did it or this
image rather is not only does it show
all of the mutations
you've got jack
you've got mipple
you've got link um and then there's a
few others that i didn't even discuss
there's also sybil that's over here
but what's great is that you can also
see that you've got
all of your epigenetic regulators idh1
and 2 tet and here you can see that
when you're not producing
not using idh102 the way that you're
supposed to then you alter the way that
tet is ultimately going to be used
there's also the easy h2 mutations
contributing to there's that lysine
27 on histone 3
and asxl1
which is involved in
h of the histone two but it's also
involved in histone three ivh
um
uh ik2 ikz f1 mutations which we didn't
discuss today but those have also been
um
suggested in some myeloproliferative
disorders as well and then the the last
epigenetic regulator here
dna methyltransferase three all of which
are contributing to an altered phenotype
in these particular cells
um one additional uh molecule that's
been suggested as being problematic
as an epigenetic regulator is jack 2.
wait a second i thought jack 2 was just
mutated and it causes some problems and
as acting as a tyrosine kinase
it's also been shown to potentially
function in an epigenetic capacity as
well
in which jack ii is supposed to just be
seen in cytoplasm
interacting with
its
various receptors however it's also been
observed within the nucleus so how is it
possible that it's getting into the
nucleus and what in the world is it
doing there
it appears that it's contributing to
chromatin compaction and the um uh some
post-translational modifications to
histone three again
uh it's been shown to phosphorylate
histone three and displace a molecule
called hp1a
which sorry hp1 alpha which is involved
in
altering your chromatin to
heterochromatin
jack 2 has also been shown to interact
with a protein-arginine methyl
transferase shown right here
prmt5 and
and to help to phosphorylate that
molecule
notice here that the jac2 v617f molecule
is what is predominantly functioning to
aberrantly alter these proteins to
change chromatin compaction
and that when we end up having that
mutant jack
molecule that this reduces the
methylation that's seen genome-wide
within
within the nucleus and that's
contributing in a potential epigenetic
pathway in a way that we weren't
necessarily thinking object to to be
able to function within these cells
so now to some of the therapeutic
uh possibilities for epigenetics
um there are uh histone duacetylase
inhibitors and dna methyltransferase
inhibitors that are fda approved
um d-cytobeam and azeocytodeane are two
of the
dna methyl transferase inhibitors that
are commonly used and varenistat is the
histone deacetylase inhibitor that has
been shown to be effective as well
and if you look up here at the top you
can you can see that you've got you're
changing your closed chromatin
to an open chromatin when you have um
histone acetyl transferation
transferase and when you have a histone
deacetylation
occurring you're conju you're taking
that open chromatid and changing it back
into closed chromatin
so um
aside from the uh
molecules that are being used that are
fda approved certainly we need to know
that um there is a
epigenetic
mechanism being involved in one of these
myeloproliferative neoplasms and it
makes it much easier to be able to use
these therapeutic options
but there are
still some problems with the fda
approved molecules and of course we
don't have 100 cure rates so that being
said there's lots of other molecules
that are in um that are being tested
most of which have not yet made it to
clinical trials um zebularine is one of
those that
has been tested clinically it does
appear to to be orally bioavailable
which is very nice and it functions as a
cytodean analog such that it forms a
covalent bond with dna methyl
transferase
um
and it's going to be incorporated into
the malignant cells um
certainly because those cells are
dividing more rapidly than others so we
see this incorporation during dna
replication and then dna methyl
transferases interacting with this
molecule um
at that time the problem so far that's
been observed with this particular drug
is that we have to have much higher
concentrations than we've seen with some
of the other drugs
which most commonly leads to some kind
of a cytotoxicity
mg 98 is an uh anti-sense
oligonucleotide or some kind of an rna
inhibitor if you will um and it has made
it into phase one clinical trial trials
um but there's been really inconsistent
um outcomes with this particular
compound
in that it's not been showing to um
knock down the dnmt1 molecule the way
that it was
intended to uh and so we don't
necessarily see great uptake
with this particular drug but
essentially it's supposed to be
inhibiting
by acting as a um
antisense molecule
we also have rg108 which is a dnmt1
inhibitor there aren't too many dnmt3
inhibitors as of yet but dnmt1 has been
tested in order to identify
the potential for for other uh dna
methyl transferase inhibitors for the
future but also in just reducing
methylation in general
so it has been um this rg108 has been
shown to interact with the active uh
with the the enzyme binding site
such that uh it reduces the ability of
this molecule to be of dnnts to be able
to methylate the dna
but it doesn't seem to be working as
well as does azo or d-citabine and so
it's not necessarily going to be moving
much further within trials
there are some targeted therapies that
have been tested as well dznap is one of
those
in which um it uh inhibits the um
easy h2 molecule from being able to uh
methylate the way that it normally has
been
um and it's also shown to reduce the
amount of that prc2 complex
that polycom repressive complex
um it's shown to so far promote
apoptosis in some cancer cell lines
which is a very good thing but has not
been shown to be effective yet in humans
and it does appear uh importantly to
promote erythroid differentiation so we
can at least see that we are blocking
that hematopoietic stem cell
self-renewal and allowing for
differentiation to take place a couple
of idh102 inhibitors
have been used
but they're um
not yet in clinical trials
so there are a number of epigenetic
modifiers that are in involved in um the
mylo proliferative neoplasms
uh asxl1 and tet2 have so far been shown
to be the most common but again these
are very very new so we might be finding
that there are several others and we
might be finding the more patients that
are tested that there are actually
higher incidences and some of the others
over time
um it's still important to figure out
what's going on outside of jack 2 and
nipple mutations even though those are
the two more common mutations that are
seen in some of the mpn's
and certainly to start addressing some
of the
additional
therapies that are going to be um useful
um beyond just the traditional therapies
the epigenetic drugs might be very very
useful a paper just came out in blood i
believe it was last week actually
looking at two mutations and
and some of these
uh um
epigenetic drugs and showing that if we
know that there's a tattoo mutation then
it's probably going to be very effective
to use an epigenetic regulator
so i i like this little cartoon here um
because i've i've actually been known i
could accuse myself of saying this um
several times if if they ask you
anything and you don't know just say
it's due to epigenetics i think there's
lots of times where we um where we're
looking at certain gene mutations and
assuming that's got to be it that's the
only way
and it turns out that there are so many
other potential molecules that could be
involved in the pathogenesis of these
myeloproliferative disorders that we've
got to look beyond just some of these
basic gene sequences
okay i will um
take a look at a couple of questions
so um
we have a question here asking about
whether or not there's epigenetic
treatments and i think the last part of
this pretty much just
explains some of that uh and here's a
question about dz nap on ovarian cancer
cells
i apologize i don't actually know if
there's if it's been used on ovarian
cancer i was sort of focused uh i tend
to be
focused on the hematologic side of
things and i do um
i do uh consider myself a hematologist
in a molecular diagnostician so um i've
been looking mostly on those i'm not
sure if there are any additional um
effects of the dz nip on ovarian cancer
cells
i'll hang around for a little bit if
there are any other questions
um
otherwise i uh i thank you for coming i
thank you for um being a part of the
bioconference live
presentations and
um
i hope that you have gotten a little bit
out of this thank you all for coming
and uh we'll see you next year maybe
you